it's game show week ross and to
celebrate we're gamifying the news
are you ready oh i'm ready it's pop
culture showdown
[Music]
and we're the contestants today oh and
it is one
i am so excited we're going to play with
each other
and every game show needs a host and i
know a host who's the most qualified
when it comes to pop culture or anything
else in the biz
he's the host of entertainment tonight
now in its 40th season
please welcome our friend kevin frazier
hi kevin drew how are you
oh kevin i love how ross i i love you
this makes me so happy kevin thank you i
i am so excited to be a game show host
right now drew
all right well before we play you
brought us an amazing clip
from the et archives take it away kevin
tell us who it is
yeah bob barker because the price is
right is the longest running game show
on tv and bob
hosted it for almost 35 years starting
all the way back in 1972.
he is the greatest of all time the goat
as we like to say and
when the american tv icon sat down with
et back in 1986
he talked about why games and game shows
have such staying power check this out
well i believe that uh americans are
game oriented
and we play games at home as
children preschool children families
play games together
they play games as they travel in
automobiles or on airplanes
and we play games on social occasions
and games were popular
on radio many years ago and it was only
a natural transition to television
okay i love him we love games that's
what he told us and
because we love games we're gonna play
you both love pop culture
and we're about to put that to a test i
get a little competitive kevin
we're gonna like confer with each other
and then tell kevin the answer okay
okay perfect got it here's the first
question warner brothers just announced
wonka a prequel to charlie and the
chocolate factory who is reportedly
pegged to follow up johnny depp
as the new wonka is it timothy chalamet
donald glover or florence pugh
okay i do not know this answer either
and i'm so mad that i don't um
okay lock us in on it timothy
you're gonna go with timothy yeah hey
yeah you are right
timothy here's the answer um now let me
just say this there is some talk
that tom holland could be a part of this
it's a prequel as i mentioned and warner
brothers just announced it will be
released
in 2023 so get ready for that okay
we need that question two this actor
just revealed to the world we've been
calling them by the wrong name
is it kate blanchett
her actual name's kate blanket and
hathaway
she's an annie not an ann or dwayne the
rock johnson
he actually prefers the stone
uh i like the rock's jacket there i'm
just focusing on what's important
um i'm gonna lock it it's b
i saw this on a headline somewhere
online right you are on the money it is
b anne hathaway anne hathaway wants to
be called
annie from now on when she got her sag
card back when she was 14 years old
she put anne in there and everybody's
called her aunt since but the only
person
who really calls her aunt is her mama
when she's mad call her annie from now
on
here we go question number three you
guys are on fire right now
what celeb couple recently welcomed a
new baby
named kai is it gigi hadid and zayn
malik
sophie turner and joe jonas justin
timberlake and jessica
beale let's go with a mm-hmm
are you going with a yeah we're doing
that you got it right
it is a okay so here's the deal
gigi's baby girl is named kai and
she didn't make a big announcement she
just changed her instagram handle to
kai's mom
and everybody hopped on it okay that is
the cutest thing i've ever heard
i love that okay we have one last
question take it away kevin
okay what disney stars hit single is
currently the most
listened to song on the planet is it
demi lovato
sabrina carpenter or olivia rodrigo
we're cool like you know what the kids
like we just talked about her all week
last week
you are right her single just debuted at
number one
it has more than 58 million
views on youtube the official video um
people are losing their minds and going
crazy
all right hey listen that's our game but
you guys were perfect four for four you
were on the money you are
winners here with the pop culture
showdown thank you so much thank you
kevin please let's do this again because
this was the best
fun ever and i hear that you have a
little clip maybe for us
before we go i do want to show you
something and you know recently we
talked to jennifer love hewitt on e.t
and she was absolutely glowing about an
amazing experience
that she recently had check this out oh
wow
i just did your barrymore show and i
have been
literally like she's everything to me
personally
i just love her so much and we really
had such a good time and like i feel
like we had sort of like a heart soul
connection
and after the interview she sent flowers
to my house
and said like let's be friends let's do
this like let's take this
out of this business and like let's be
people who are in each other's lives and
i mean i think i cried for two hours
straight when there's somebody that you
admire or you look up to
and they take time for you or
they're a person who just reaches out to
you at the right moment
it's beautiful i did
and she did and it's on we're becoming
friends
i'm really looking forward to getting to
know someone who i've loved from afar
for so long but
it's on oh drew that is so cool
kevin you're on entertainment tonight
every weeknight
[Music]
you